Hello, Marvel fans.
We're here with
Benedict Cumberbatch
who plays Doctor Strange.
You have had quite the
busy life, my friend.
Yep.
What is it like to dive
into the Marvel multiverse?
Marvel is a fun place to be
right now as Doctor Strange.
That's all I will say.
And yeah, you know,
he brings something
very interesting to this film.
But most of all, having worked
with Tom, not just on this,
but on a couple
of other projects,
it's just wonderful to
be by his side again
and doing what we do.
And establishing and maturing
and growing that relationship
is fantastic.
What is it like
bringing Doctor Strange
into the world of Spider-Man?
A lot of fun.
You know, I get to play the
grown up surrounded by kids.
I can say that.
They're half my
age, they are kids.
I'm blown away by
their professionalism,
by the atmosphere
they create on set,
by the fun it is
to be on that set.
Jon Watts is a
phenomenal director.
He's such a joy to work with.
He really, he's great
on the granular,
he gives you context
to understand
where your place is in the
story and the development of it.
Even when all the story
hasn't been finished,
which is often the way with
these films at the time
of production starting.
And it is just fun
from start to finish.
What goes through
Doctor Strange's mind
after saving worlds
and universes,
a young Peter Parker
comes up saying, hey,
can you craft a spell
to have people forget?
I think the most that
goes through his mind
is to see in the
film, it's like yeah,
sure I want to help you out kid.
You did great back there.
And you're one of them and
us and you know, we're doing,
we're all on the same team here.
So sure I'll help a friend out.
It doesn't really take
into account that he's
still a kid at high school.
And in trying to people please,
or going yeah, OK, let's
do one for the team, yeah.
Some crazy stuff is unleashed.
And that's where
the relationship
starts to evolve and mature.
And that's what I'm
really excited about.
I mean, there's
some crazy reveals
and fun spills and
thrills in this, but also,
for me as an actor,
the thing that
matters most is that emotional
connection to a character
and the people who
surround him and the world
that surrounds him.
So with Tom and I, that's a
really beautiful relationship
that's kicking off.